ce qu'il faut peut-être retenir
finalement de l'ové en dehors des
données statistiques
c'est la capacité de faire remonter le
ressenti des étudiants c'est à dire
comment vivent t-il eu leur expérience
leur parcours de vie leur parcours
d'études au fil des années on voit bien
et l'enquète 2020 le confirme qu' il y à
des évolutions mais elles sont
relativement lente
elles s'inscrivent dans la durée et je
mets à part le confinement et les
conséquences de la crise de cette année
noël nous y reviendrons également
donc on a cette volonté de se rapprocher
d'une réalité qui sinon ne transparaît
pas beaucoup les relais on en dise un
mot avec avec
monsieur le président les relais
intermédiaires que sont les associations
ou les syndicats ou et où les élus dans
les conseils vie universitaire on peine
vraiment à faire cette traduction des
besoins et des finalement des
difficultés ou au contraire des attentes
des étudiants dans leur vie dans leur
vie d'étudiant qui n'est pas que la vie
sur les campus
on est dans une acception très large
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qui se
passait dans les années 80 de ce qu'est
la vie étudiante on est sur ce qu'on
appelle beaucoup aujourd'hui
l'expérience étudiants c'est à dire la
construction d'un parcours d'études oui
certes mais un parcours d'autonomie et
un parcours de construction de la
personne humaine est en lien avec ses
pairs en lien avec les enseignants
chercheurs en lien avec un environnement
qui lui aussi doit être analysé de façon
concomitante
donc ça c'était le premier point que je
voulais reprendre et un second qui est
vraiment va revenir à plusieurs reprises
dans notre présentation c'est que il est
totalement impossible de parler
aujourd'hui des étudiants ou d'une
population étudiante ça n'a aucun
strictement aucun sens
et ces deux prisons plus vrai et ça
l'est encore plus après la crise nous
avons évidemment vous connaissez tous la
pression démographique qui fait que nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec un nombre
d'étudiants qui a considérablement
augmenté depuis les années 70 et qui
fait que les universités et les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
au sens large ont dû s'adapter mais ils
se sont adaptés avec un autre une autre
caractéristique qui s'est imposé au fil
des années c'est la différenciation
entre les catégories d'étudiants et nous
verrons peut-être tout à l'heure que
cette différenciation elle s'est accru
fortement depuis la crise et elle s'est
aussi révélé de plus en plus importante
entre type d'établissement entre
catégories d'établissements
c'est à dire qu'on a on a
mais il s'agit pas de dire que c'est à
deux vitesses il s'agit simplement qu'il
y à une réalité complexe qu'il faut la
prendre comme tel et l'analyser comme
tel sans aller à des généralisations
qu'on a malheureusement de temps en
temps l'occasion de lire en particulier
dans les médias donc sûr c'est une fois
qu'on a on a bien ces deux perspectives
en tête ont effectivement si on replace
les résultats de cette enquête 2020 on
voit qu'elle s'inscrit d'abord dans la
durée et dans les constats précédent de
donc on mieux une stabilisation mais il
y a même des points particuliers qui ont
donné lieu à des progrès ont certes
toujours en prenant des proportions qui
sont qui reste tout à fait raisonnable
si je puis dire dans dans dans les
évolutions mais néanmoins sur par
exemple deux points importants le
premier temps le sentiment qu'on les
étudiants par rapport à l'heure au
déroulement de leurs études
c'est à dire la satisfaction qui peuvent
exprimer sur l'organisation des études
sur ce que ça leur rapporte
on voit qu'en 2020 64 % sont satisfaits
ou très satisfaits
ce qui est quand même une amélioration
par rapport à l'an qué 2016 où il était
à 60 % ce qui sur l'ensemble
puisque je précise une petite un petit
point on a bien eu soixante mille
résultats exploiter ses dires compléter
et exploitable entre guillemets des
questionnaires mais on avait consulté
deux cent cinquante mille étudiants avec
un panel évidemment représentant
l'ensemble de l'enseignement supérieur
et pas seulement les universités je
ferme la parenthèse donc cette
proportion est au regard des
insatisfaits évidemment en corrélation
on a en 2020 10 % qui sont insatisfaits
alors que nous étions effectivement à 11
% de l'ensemble très insatisfaits dans
l' enquête de 2016 alors en même temps
sur le contenu même de la formation on
avait là aussi 71 % d'étudiants
satisfait sur les contenus de formation
donc on voit bien que 2020 à l'aide dans
un sens positif c'est le cas aussi pour
les perspectives d'avenir en 2016 54 %
des étudiants estimaient leur chance
d'insertion en france cette fois bonne
ou très bonne contre 14% qui les
estimaient mauvaise ou très mauvaise et
en 2020 on est passé à 68 % pour les
étudiants optimiste toujours au sujet de
leur insertion en france et oui % pour
ceux qui étaient disons plutôt
pessimiste à l'étranger même même même
écart c'est à dire qu'en 2016 40 %
estimaient des chances d'insertion à
l'étranger bonne ou très bonne
21% mauvaise ou très mauvaise et en 2020
nous passons à 45 % et 18 %
dernier élément positif n'est ce pas le
dernier mais disons celui que nous
évoquerons il porte sur le
la notion financière la notion
économique la situation des étudiants
alors dans l'ensemble on pendant l'année
universitaire on a une proportion
d'étudiants qui se déclare enfin qui
déclarent connaître des difficultés
financières importantes ou très
importante et on a un cinquième des
étudiants qui le déclare ce qui est en
baisse par rapport à 2016 on était alors
la baisse encore une fois est modeste si
on était à 23%
mais c'est significatif puisque ont
laissé ce type d'écart mesure sur une
population plus grand bien entendu des
vraies évolutions en 2020 nous avons nos
avenues ans 26% des étudiants qui
déclarait ne pas avoir assez d'argent
pour couvrir leurs besoins mensuels et
nous étions à 2 29 % en 2016 et quand on
regarde je je je fais une remarque
générale quand on regarde la situation
économique des étudiants il faut se
rappeler là aussi qu'on est dans un
contexte très différent d'un
de ce qui se passe par exemple dans les
estimations de l'insee sur les la
population jeune
il n'y a pas de budget étudiant au sens
strict il y à une reconstitution des
ressources que perçoivent les étudiants
avec trois sources principales de 3
origine principale donc les aides bien
sûr familiale les aides publiques est
quelque chose qui s'est affirmé
progressivement dans budget le budget
des étudiants ont reconstitué c'est à
dire les activités rémunérées et vous je
ne rentre pas dans les détails mais vous
verrez on vous laissera d'ailleurs
quelques quelques documents et je
transmettrai un document plus détaillé
et chiffré pour pour votre compte rendu
mais vous verrez que dans cette activité
rémunérée là aussi attention de ne pas
faire des raccourcis trop rapide en est
on entend toujours un étudiant sur deux
travaille il a besoin pour vivre de tels
niveaux de financement et serra c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça d'ailleurs
on est à 38 % exactement dans la
dernière enquête et ce panel d'activités
rémunéré il va du baby sitting
avec des revenus alors modeste au
demeurant mais qui sont qui peuvent être
aussi régulier ça va des stages liés à
leurs études en particulier dans le
domaine de la santé
et ça va aussi effectivement à toute une
série de petits jobs la vente le
commerce etc
on doit là encore faire très attention à
la concentrer l'analyse sur ce qui crée
problème est qu est ce qui crée problème
dans une activité rémunérée c'est
l'intensité le rythme est ce que on est
sur une activité intense et qui
contrarie effectivement la possibilité
pour les étudiants de suivre leurs
études conviennent jours par semaine
combien d'heures etc ou bien est-ce
qu'on est sur un job ou une activité
ponctuelle qui ne remet pas en cause la
possibilité de suivre des études
et ça c'est d'autant plus important
qu'on verra tout à l'heure avec la crise
c'est un des facteurs majeurs qui a
entraîné des conséquences extrêmement
négatives pour les budgets et la
situation économique des étudiants en
2020 donc on est bien là sur une notion
qui relève d'un examen économique au
sens au sens strict
et c'est un des points de faiblesse
qu'on aura probablement l'occasion
d'évoquer c'est à dire qu'on a on a des
difficultés on n'a pas les outils
mesures qui conviennent en particulier
dans le domaine économique
et c'est une piste je pense pour les
décideurs dans un prochain avenir
ce serait vraiment de remettre à plat un
système qui est largement illisible y
compris de la part des étudiants eux
mêmes qu'ils ont
qui ont droit qui ne savent pas toujours
à qui s'adresser
et c'est encore plus vrai avec la crise
parce qu'il a il ya eu des très bien il
ya eu des tas de mesures d'urgence
pendant tout l'été dans tout l'est dans
tous les secteurs mais il va falloir
vraiment un moment donné remettre de la
cohérence et de redonner du sens à ce
qui est une politique de soutien au sens
financier du terme de façon à cibler
bien évidemment sur les populations qui
en ont le plus besoin c'est à dire les
plus fragiles alors au delà ces trois
points peut-être que sur le logement il
ya très peu de modifications on est
toujours sur une répartition entre les
dix ans le domicile des parents
quelques sur quel que soit ce demi si ça
peut être les parents séparés ça peut
être bon en gros domicile ce qu'on
appelle la cohabitation familia avec
également la location ou la colocation
je rappelle que pour par exemple les
locations en résidence universitaire on
a un chiffre très faible 1 qui est de
l'ordre de 12%
donc on a bien
[Musique]
pendant la période universitaire et donc
on a globalement une difficulté qui
d'ailleurs est majeur sur le sur le
logement et c'est toujours vrai avec
l'étude 2020 avec l'en-tête 2020 on a à
la fois des difficultés parce que c'est
le montant du loyer qui est le premier
poste de dépenses dans ce fameux budget
étudiant premier poste de dépense très
variable en fonction du lieu de
résidence est encore une fois en
fonction de ce qui caractérise
l'étudiant est ce qu'il est boursier non
boursiers ce qu'il a une aide indirecte
de la famille etc etc
donc on a on a là une clarification et
je n'évoquerai pas parce que c'est un
sujet complexe s'il en est la nécessité
aussi de bien regarder l'ensemble des
aides et des mesures de soutien y
compris l'aide personnalisée au jeu au
logement
on a là quelque chose qui est parfois
décalés par rapport à la réalité vécue
par les étudiants lorsqu'ils sont dans
un mode de logement qui occasionne des
difficultés supplémentaires et notamment
dans les métropoles urbaines donc
logement peu de modifications en tout
cas avant la crise on est dedans on est
sur une stabilité
alors au delà de ce constat à la fois de
stabilité et d'amélioration partiel mais
importante quand même des points de
fragilité qui sont apparus del'enquête
d'ailleurs 2016 mais très conforté dans
l' enquête 2020 et ça concerne l'état de
santé des étudiants puisque
en 2016 on était toujours alors il faut
quand même avoir ça en arrière-plan on a
un constat qui est émis par tous les
étudiants ils se sentent globalement en
bonne santé c'est qu'il se perçoivent en
bonne santé
la une des réponses qui revient souvent
mais pourquoi avez vous renoncé aux
soins est ce qu'on peut penser que c'est
par rapport à une raison financière
économique et cetera souvent c'est non
ça va s'arranger tout seul en fait ces
caractéristiques d'une population jeune
et qui n'a pas forcément une intégrer
les difficultés potentielles de santé
alors ça change avec avec la crise du co
lead mais ce qui par contre était
frappant c'était le tout ce qui tourne
autour des fragilités d'ordre
psychologique
et là on est passé de 20 % d'étudiants
qui le déclarait en 2016 ce qui était
déjà ce qui était déjà quand même
important à 30% et notamment sur le
chiffre aussi de renoncement aux soins
on est passé là aussi est cette fois
vraiment pour des raisons financières à
prendre 3 % donc une alerte
une alerte qui s'est retrouvé tout à
fait confirmé par la suite et même
amplifié bien entendu par ce qui a été
constaté au niveau de fa des
conséquences de la pandémie
donc globalement
on est face à un exercice un petit peu
compliqué pour nous observatoire de la
vie étudiante et un peu inédit c'est
qu'on avait des constats on a des
données qui sont très riches et qui vont
maintenant être exploitées puisque le
principe avec ce type d' enquête c'est
que nous allons mobiliser des équipes de
recherche des économies sous des
statisticiens pour aller plus loin et
pour approfondir ce que nous disent les
étudiants dans danser dans cette enquête
mais il se trouve que tout ceci s'est
passé au printemps 2020 et que nous
avons bien entendu immédiatement même si
à l'époque qu'il faut être tout à fait
honnête nous n'avons pas pu anticiper
une durée aussi importante de la crise
nous nous étions tous persuadés que ça
allait s'arrêter à l'été et qu'on allait
progressivement revenir vers quelque
chose entre guillemets depuis normal et
nous n'avons pas non plus pu anticiper
des effets de prise en plus important au
fur et à mesure des périodes de
confinement déconfinement couvre-feu et
ses dons pour essayer quand même
d'avancer et d'avoir une matière
première si j'ose dire un peu plus un
peu plus utile
nous avons relancé donc auprès de 6000
étudiants qui avaient déjà été
questionnés dans la première enquête
une enquête courte beaucoup plus courte
que la première et qui essayait vraiment
de percevoir ce qui était en train
d'arriver pour eux un bouleversement qui
ressortait qui ressort toujours quand on
vois j'ai vu j'ai lu les premiers
témoignages le bouleversement qui à la
fois dans l'espace il ya plus d'unité de
lieu entre formation recherche dans les
labos et vie étudiante et ça c'est
quelque chose qui déstructure totalement
lala l'identité étudiante en quelque
sorte ce sont des mots très forts qui
qu'on a entendu c'est à dire la perte de
sens finalement c'est quoi être étudiant
quand il n'y a plus nécessité d'aller en
cours quand on ne peut plus se voir dans
les lieux de socialisation et quand on
est coupé par froid de ce qu'ils
faisaient aussi le lien avec
l'enseignant chercheur qu'on est revenus
y compris quand on est doctorant et
qu'on était des as salariés on est
revenu dans sa famille tout ceci brasser
dans un ensemble anxiogène quand même un
qui était de ne pas savoir la durée
comment on allait sortir de cette crise
encore faudrait-il qu'on sache
aujourd'hui on est on est véritablement
devant des conditions de bouleversements
et qui se sont traduites vraiment dans
les réponses à lenquête à la deuxième
enquête
peut-être si tu peux parler peut-être à
partir donc 2d sur la deuxième question
c'est à dire par rapport aux ce contexte
général qu'est ce qui s'est passé
finalement et qu'est ce qui ce qui
ressort de notre dans notre enquête
confinement si oui bonjour à toutes et à
tous et merci pour l'opportunité de
présenter un peu nos travaux alors donc
ça ce qu'a présenté et monique rousseau
ce sont les résultats de notre enquête
réalisée donc à partir du mois de mars
et jusqu'au mois de mai 2020 quand on
était déjà dans une situation de
confinement mais on interrogeait les
étudiants sur leur situation antérieure
leur demandant un petit peu de faire un
effort d'imagination et de se rappeler
comment était la vie étudiante au moment
où les interroger et puis en juillet
et on a lancé sept postes enquête
puisqu'on a réinterrogé 45 mille
étudiants
parmi ceux qui acceptaient être
réinterrogé et donc sur ces quarante
cinq mille qu'on a réinterrogé y en a 6
milles 130 qui nous ont répondu et donc
ça nous a permis de faire un bilan il
était au moment où ils allaient passer
souvent les examens et donc de faire un
bilan du confinement après la session
d'examens et de voir un peu comment il
se comme il avait vécu cette heure de
confinement alors le la première
observation c'est que il ya beaucoup
d'étudiants qui ont changé de logement
c'est peut-être la population qu'elle
peut changer de logement entre la
berline lui est à la période de
confinement puisque 44 % des étudiants
ont déclaré avoir changé de logement est
très souvent c'était pour se rapprocher
de leur famille donc ça c'est la
première caractéristique
ensuite en ce qui concerne les
conditions d'études on observe un
passage massif au numérique même
pratiquement exclusif avec les
inconvénients que sa pose et qui ont les
difficultés qu'ont soulever les
étudiants c'est à dire qu'il y en avait
qui étaient pas très bien équipée
n'avait pas forcément d'ordinateurs
personnels n'avaient pas forcément une
bonne connexion internet n'avait pas
forcément des espaces au calme pour
travailler et donc c'est des cd des
problèmes qui sont remontés pendant le
monde en le confinant et qui nous ont
fait remonter dans l'anc est ensuite en
ce qui concerne leur situation
économique
on observe qu'un tiers des étudiants
déclarent avoir perdu leur activité
rémunérée et ça représente plus de 200
euros de perte en terme de deux pertes
moyennes financière pour ces étudiants
et en ce qui concerne aussi l'état de
santé on observe que pour un tiers des
étudiants et présente des signes de
détresse psychologique
alors on remarque que c'est la même part
que ce que l'on observé dans enquêtes
générales ce qui montre qu'il ya sans
doute eu des interférences entre les
deux enquêtes celle qu'on les a
interrogés entre mars et mai 2020 à un
moment et c'était déjà confiné et donc
voilà on des fois on a du mal un peu à
faire la part des choses entre leurs
réponses propre confinement et leurs
réponses liées à l' enquête générale
alors quand il 2
quand ils sont entrés au domicile de
leurs parents pardon je reviens sur le
logement ils font état parfois de
conflits ça n'a pas été sans poser
problème
aussi ce retour au domicile parental
donc certain de frites à deux conflits
en aqua été confronté au décès d'un
proche par exemple il ya plein de
difficultés qui sont propres à la crise
et qu'on a pu mesurer en juillet 2020
mais sur la situation économique puisque
ce qu'il s'est passé avec l'arrêt des
activités rémunérées
c'est que dans un premier temps tout le
monde était un peu dans sous le choc et
c'est il ya un effet de sidération qui
n'était pas que pour les étudiants mais
on s'est vite aperçu que finalement le
la situation économique générale et la
difficulté qu'avait les entreprises à se
projeter avait un impact immédiat sur la
réponse attendaient les étudiants alors
ceux qui s'en sont mieux sorties c'est
ce qu'ils ont réussi à retrouver entre
guillemets des petits jobs la livraison
à domicile des plats à emporter et c'est
tout ça les étudiants se sont vraiment
ruer dessus mais par contre ce qui
faisait la structure même de l'activité
rémunérée et parfois avec même du
salariat enfin des formes beaucoup plus
solide si je puis dire
alors là c'est pour cela ça a été
véritablement beaucoup plus compliqué ça
c'est tout à fait
télescoper avec la nécessité de quitter
par exemple un logement parce que le
loyer trop élevé parce que les facteurs
se sont cumulées ce qui ressort très
nettement de notre enquête confinement
les étudiants évoquent vraiment un cumul
de facteurs de à la fois de stress le
psychologique
la prise et des ailes et multiforme et
le problème c'est que ces dimensions qui
se s'entrechoquent un peu elles ont tout
produit des effets en même temps c'est à
dire que la fermeture des locaux
universitaires l'arrêt de l'activité
rémunérée du cool isolement et donc la
difficulté psychologique à surmonter cet
isolement
tout ceci c'est vraiment cumulés dans un
espace temps extrêmement resserré et ça
ressort ça ressort vraiment tout à fait
tout à fait de façon évidente dans les
dents dans notre enquête dans notre
deuxième enquête si je puis dire avec là
aussi des mesures d'urgence finalement
qui ont été prises et qui ont été
reconnus dans cette dans cette enquête
par les étudiants si là qu'on leur avait
demandé est ce que vous estimez que vous
avez eu beaucoup d'informations de la
part de vos établissements
est ce que vous avez eu suffisamment
dead alors je parle bien du premier
confinement c'est à dire que la durée
ensuite fait que la situation s'est
évidemment compliqué mais la réponse
était plutôt positive
oui ils ont eu pour beaucoup d'ailleurs
des problèmes de connexion numérique
mais moins que ce qu'on pouvait penser
c'est à dire que ça s'est finalement
relativement bien passé parce que les
établissements ont réagi il ya eu des
plans d'acquisition de matériels il ya
eu des collectivités territoriales sont
beaucoup possi progressivement sont
montés en puissance pour aider à
l'équipement des étudiants
donc c'est à la fois une situation qui
était brutal mais qui avec une
mobilisation assez sensible est forte
quand même de tous les acteurs de la vie
étudiante ça va de bien sûr des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
qui ont même au delà de ce qui était
naturellement le vecteur de soutien
financier c'est-à-dire la cvec la
contribution à la vie étudiante et de
campus qui a été très très utilisés
au-delà des aides qui ont été mises en
place par le ministère via les crous et
qui ont immédiatement réagi et qui ont
mis en place toute une série de
dispositifs on voit que le si j'ose dire
le pire a été évité au moment de la
rupture au moment où se sont produits
tous et tous ses effets alors l'analyse
de ce qui se passe depuis et plus et
plus évidemment complexe parce que plus
la crise dure et plus on a un double
phénomène finalement on a un phénomène
on a certains psychologues ont parlé de
phénomène de glissement quand on a parlé
aussi pour les personnes âgées
d'ailleurs à un moment donné dans la
crise c'est à dire que il ya une espèce
de d'usure de fatick ça ressort très
bien dire des témoignages que vous avez
eues on a ce phénomène de qui s'est
installée et qui n'était pas encore
perceptible à ce point dans notre
enquête confinement donc là il ya un
décalage on en est tout à fait conscient
et on à l'attention des videmment de
continuer d'aller plus loin mais on est
aussi ce qui était déjà perceptible
c'est que ces signes d'anxiété ces
signes de difficultés à organiser son
temps personnel
il n'y a pas il n'ya pas réellement de
surprise si je puis dire vous savez
exactement les mêmes conséquences
négatives dans les analystes qui
commencent à sortir sur le télétravail
il ya vraiment des grosses similitudes
c'est à dire que mes ans avec des avec
des étudiants qui eux n'étaient pas
forcément dans un cadre de travail qui
les auraient préparé à cela si je puis
dire mais on a ce sentiment général de
ne plus savoir situer sa formation les
études que l'on poursuit sa remise en
cause des choix d'orientation cela remet
en cause éventuellement le fait de se
projeter au-delà du master et d'aller en
doctorat on sent que tout est en train
de bouger en quelque sorte entre licence
master et doctorat c'est à dire que les
priorités ne sont plus perçus de la même
façon parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui va
devenir dans un avenir dans un avenir
proche
et ça me fait aborder la question que
vous avez
posez tout à l'heure c'est à dire
finalement est ce que est ce que ça
s'est passé de la même façon pour tout
le monde
alors la réponse évidemment est négative
bien sûr que non puisque d'abord il y
avait déjà des différenciations avant et
elle se sont évidemment confirmé mais en
plus il y en a il y en a eu des
nouvelles pour faire très très court et
listant rêve à compléter on a des cannes
on a vraiment des catégories d'étudiants
qui ont plus souffert que d'autres les
étudiants étrangers en premier
puisqu'ils se sont retrouvés coupés et
de l'aide familiale et éventuellement
d'un petit travail qu'ils avaient trouvé
en arrivant en france et avec un soutien
des pairs qui n'était pas aussi
organisés que pour les associations
françaises éventuellement ou par ou par
filière quand comme on l'a pu voir par
exemple dans les 8 et donc on a les
étudiants étrangers on a les étudiants
les plus âgés c'est eux qui est lé plus
de 26 ans engagé justement dans des
dents des études doctorales et qui du
coup pour certains ont perdu aussi une
source de revenu et on a les étudiants
enfin primo-entrants puisque je rappelle
que la génération inscrits à la rentrée
2020 c'est celle qui finalement n'a rien
connu de l'université je parviens
d'université là cette fois les grandes
écoles clairement s'en sort beaucoup
mieux il faut il faut vraiment faire ce
constat pour des raisons évidentes
d'encadrement pédagogique d'organisation
aussi qui est peut-être plus sur un
accompagnement personnalisé et ça c'est
un grand défi qui va se poser aux
universités mais ce sera une nécessité
absolue
et donc on a on a des différences qui se
sont clairement accentué qui ressortent
tout à fait de notre enquête
oui alors comme l'a très bien rappelé au
micro au début de l'entretien
les travaux de l'eau veut contribuer à
montrer qu'effectivement il ya un
étudiant moyen mais il ya une diversité
d'étudiants qui est que nos enquêtes
permettre un petit peu de cerner alors
d'abord en terme d'orientation fait si
on regarde l'origine sociale c'est sûr
que les différences d'orientation sont
importantes c'est qu'on va avoir des
élèves des étudiants beaucoup plus
favorisés dans les filières comme les
classes préparatoires ou les grands
établissements où les écoles de commerce
et des profils moins favorisés dans les
sts par exemple les eyzies ut le les
questions portaient aussi sur les
différences selon le sexe ont séparé
l'orientation va être différente méchant
qu'il ya aussi des variables importantes
et qu'on n'a pas forcément tête alors
yale il ya là l'origine migratoire aussi
qui permet de distinguer différentes
orientations
selon les étudiants avec par exemple une
orientation plus importante des enfants
descendants de deux parents immigrés
dans des filières courtes
professionnelle dans l'enseignement
supérieur
et puis il ya aussi donc ses différentes
filières qui sont alimentés par des
profils d'étudiants différents se
caractérise aussi pas d expérience
différente de l'enseignement supérieur
puisqu'on a des emplois du temps de
beaucoup plus chargé par exemple dans
des filières comme la santé ou les
classes préparatoires et des emplois du
temps plus léger en terme d'heures de
présence de cours est donc ça permet
aussi aux étudiants de d'avoir d'exercer
des activités rémunérées de manière plus
ou moins importante selon leur filière
et avec les effets qu'on connaît donc
comme l'a rappelé au micro effectivement
on a décidé d aigle des activités
beaucoup plus concurrents des études
exercée par les étudiants en filière
sciences humaines par exemple à
l'université puisque voilà du coup
l'arbitrage se fait souvent au niveau de
l'emploi est effectivement l'âge aussi
des étudiants va être très important en
ce qui concerne la cohabitation par
exemple les étudiants plus ils sont
jeunes et plus ont de fortes chances
d'être cohabitent en mai par exemple les
élèves de classes préparatoires aussi
sont beaucoup plus qu'aux habitants
alors la variable cohabitation est très
importante il me semble parce que c'est
ce qui permet de repérer un peu vain
quand on parlait des difficultés à
mesurer les ressources des étudiants
la cohabitation cette variable
fondamentale parce que tout ne passe pas
par des transferts monétaires qu'on
pourrait mesurer et quantifier et l'aide
familiale c'est aussi simplement hébergé
ses enfants qui sont étudiants leur
donner de la nourriture et beaucoup de
services qui ne passe pas par des
transferts monétaires et donc quand on
regarde les budgets étudiants vraiment
au sens ce financier on a l'impression
que les plus pauvres c'est les étudiants
en classes préparatoires
or ils sont jeunes ils sont souvent
qu'aux habitants donc à la fin le but
j'ai dont il dispose est tout petit mais
si on venait intègre toutes ces aides
qui ne sont pas monétaire qui ne sont
pas des transferts financiers sa fausse
un petit peu la vision qu'on peut avoir
des étudiants qui apparaissent comme
très riches parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de
revenus beaucoup de ressources d'emplois
il peut être beaucoup plus vulnérable
parce qu'en réalité ils utilisent
beaucoup d'heures de travail qui vont
être un concurrent des études et donc je
pense qu'effectivement les ressources
des étudiants c'est vraiment très
différent des ressources qu'on peut
mesurer dans les autres populations les
jeunes les adultes les salariés il faut
avoir ça en tête et donc l'arrêt de
cohabitation c'est une variable qui est
très importante
alors sur l'état de santé on perçoit
aussi des inégalités en fonction des
différentes caractéristiques puisque
simplement quand on regarde les
étudiants satisfaits de leur état de
santé général on a moins d'étudiantes
qui se déclare satisfaite que
d'étudiants 65% contre 76 on a moins
d'étudiants étrangers par rapport aux
étudiants français 66% contre 70% et les
les étudiants de milieu social populaire
à 66% on se considère en bonne santé
alors qu'ils sont 76%
parmi les étudiants de milieu social
super donc c'est toutes ces variables
finalement se recoupent et il ya des
variables que si très importante et vous
l'avez dit c'est la map territoriale où
effectivement l'expérience étudiant doit
être très différente selon le lieu
d'habitation ne serait-ce que quand on
regarde les différences de loyer en
fonction de la ville d'habitation on a
des différences très importantes qu'on
peut mesurer dans l' enquête conditions
puis voilà c'est difficile à un portrait
généralement très il faut avoir ces
différents éléments en tête
ils sont pour pour comprendre la
diversité de la population et tuteurs
sur sur ses différences
je rajouterais peut-être un point qui
porte sur les catégories
d'établissements les plans
d'investissements à venir et eliyahu
restructurer profondément la carte des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et si on regarde le côté universitaire
on voit bien que les grandes universités
fusionner n'avait pas attendu la crise
pour investir dans l'innovation
pédagogique la génériques et dago gic le
distanciait l'intelligent une
organisation était déjà en train de se
mettre en place donc ces établissements
là plus facilement que d'autres ont
réussi à sauter le pas si je puis dire
et ce qui est très important parce que
particulier pour la recherche parce que
il ya eu
une espèce de d'attentes dans certaines
universités en qui a bloqué un petit peu
le fonctionnement général des
établissements et ça ne s'est pas
produit partout de la même façon dont il
ya bien une différenciation entre
établissements qui n'est pas en soi un
problème dès lors qu' on en a conscience
et que les mesures d'accompagnement
personnalisé que j'évoquais à l'instant
et qui vont s'imposer à mon sens partout
peut-être faudra-t-il des mesures
renforcées pour les autres
établissements qui eux n'avaient pas
soit les moyens soient tout simplement
n'avait pas inscrit dans leurs projets
où il avait inscrit plus tard le
développement on parle d'une question de
maturité numérique aujourd'hui de
maturité dans la digitalisation des
enseignements et c est là il ya de très
très gros écarts entre les
établissements et tout le monde s'y est
mis un peu dans l'urgence avec les
moyens du bord simon cardona nes et
d'expression c'est logique
compréhensible en cas de crise après il
faudra vous parliez monsieur présidence
tout à l'heure de caisse qui va devoir
structurellement être prises en compte
ça c'est un objectif essentiel c'est à
dire que on est aujourd'hui sur à peu
près une des seule certitude que l'on a
c'est qu'on ne reviendra pas une
organisation
comme existait antérieurement et
notamment si on parle vie étudiante
on peut d'ores et déjà constater que la
crise actuelle
quand on s'en sortira complètement elle
aboutira à réinterroger la notion de
campus c'est quoi un campus aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors que on aura forcément non pas du
tout dit essentielle qui est une
catastrophe totale on le voit bien sur
toute une série d'éléments dont on a
déjà parlé mais un modèle hybride qui va
bien falloir reconstituer et définir qui
ne sera pas d'ailleurs homogène selon
les territoires et selon les
établissements mais on aura inventé et
je dirais que on n'est pas les premiers
à le faire il ya des expériences dans
dans beaucoup de pays qui ont déjà
avancé sur ces sujets un équilibre une
complémentarité entre présentiel et
entre enseignement et formation à
distance alors ça suppose beaucoup de
choses ça suppose d'abord la formation
des enseignants chercheurs
ce qui a péché là aussi ça ressort des
témoignages c'est que les étudiants ont
ressenti pour certains pas pour tous
bien entendu mais ont ressenti très fort
que leurs enseignants étaient aussi
perdus que et je vais donner quand même
la parole d'abord un ma collègue qui
enseigne à dos chine et qui est là la
vie de l'enseignant chercheur et et
notamment de l'écran noir août les
étudiants ferment leurs caméras ce qui
n'est pas toujours évident mais je pense
que là il ya bien un point majeur qui
est intégré très très vite toute une
série de paramètres dans la formation
des enseignants et des enseignants
chercheurs ils disent oui non mais je
crois que les étudiants nous le disent
et et les enseignants aussi il faut
réécouter ce cas soit chez les
enseignants ce que ça ça est une sphère
dossier très difficile et ça reste très
difficile pour les enseignants de ces
c'était pas le coeur du métier de
transmettre finalement un écran noir en
fait c'est pas tellement pour ça qu'on a
été formé et et on ressent on a beaucoup
ressenti en tout cas la souffrance des
étudiants ils le disent aussi dans l'
enquête ils sont nombreux à dire que ce
qui leur a manqué c'est le contact avec
les autres étudiants c'est un peu ce
sentiment d'isolement et qui est de ce
fait d'être un groupe de constituer un
groupe classe de pouvoir échanger
donc ils ont trouvé des stratégies pour
retrouver un peu de collectif mais mais
ça reste très imparfait et
et voilà c'est une souffrance des deux
côtés en tout cas c'est probablement le
premier point pour évoquer ce qui ce qui
va devoir être prises en compte
en fait on a trois temps aujourd'hui on
a eu l'urgence l'urgence du démarrage de
la crise donc il a fallu que les
établissements s'adapte que les
étudiants s'adapte tout le monde
s'adapte qu'il y ait des aides
financières nouvelles qu'ils soient
développés on a eu toute cette période
on connaît encore aujourd'hui une
deuxième phase qui est celle de la crise
qui dure qui dure et qui provoque
l'usure c'est un mot qui revient
énormément on a le sentiment que les
étudiants puisque on est quand même là
pour parler d'abord 200 sont extrêmement
inquiet et de façon de plus en plus
atone si j'allais dire c'est à dire
qu'il ne se pose plus des questions
d'urgence comme au début pensant que
tout allait redevenir un petit peu comme
avant ils attendent ils savent pas trop
quoi ils essaient de survivre alors
encore une fois pas tout ce jeu quand je
dis je je je parle de ceux qui qui sont
les plus touchés par cette clique bien
entendu tels qu'on les a définis tout à
l'heure et puis un troisième temps et je
pense que vos travaux vont nourrir
justement ce troisième temps c'est à
dire qu'il faut anticiper réfléchira
sortie de crise et la sortie de crise ça
veut dire redéfinir un certain nombre de
choses donc on vient de parler de la
formation des enseignants chercheurs
ça veut dire aussi repenser
l'organisation générale des
établissements le campus physique ne
peut plus être défini comme avant il ya
des questions d'ailleurs très complexe
immobilier qui vont se poser tout de
suite derrière
l'implantation sur les territoires il ya
toutes ces toutes ces questions là
mais il ya aussi probablement un rapport
différent de l'étudiant à son
établissement
on a bien vu quand même que la
différence qu on évoqua l'instant entre
grandes écoles et universités elle
tenait aussi à ça c'est à dire que les
étudiants des grandes écoles ont
manifesté peut-être une espèce de
reconnaissance de par rapport à leur
établissement qui s'est délitée très
vite pour les étudiants en université et
en particulier il faut bien le dire et
ça ressort là aussi de vos témoignages
dans les disciplines shs droit et une
spé alors in space est très inquiétant
puisque comme vous le savez c'est quand
même la formation de nos futurs
enseignants et je crois que là il aura
un effort très très particulier à
fournir pour pour remettre peut-être un
certain nombre de préoccupations au
coeur de la formation initiale des
enseignants je ferme
je ferme la parenthèse bon compte on a
toute une série de questions qui sont
effectivement structurelles et la qui
dépasse totalement la réponse à des
difficultés conjoncturelles liées la
crise ça veut dire aussi probablement
regarder les équilibres entre pilotage
national pilotage local et quand on dit
local c'est l'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur en lien avec
les crous en lien avec les collectivités
et ça veut dire quand même aussi que ce
qui se traduit un petit peu dans tout ce
qu'on est en train de dire c'est que
l'échelon du territoire a été celui qui
a été immédiatement mobilisés sollicité
à la fois dans l'urgence et dans et dans
la gestion de la crise sur l'année c'est
à dire que c'est bien là où on a essayé
de d'ailleurs on voit ces derniers
ces dernières semaines il ya des
plateformes qui se met en place en
collaboration avec les collectivités
plusieurs régions ont vraiment
constituer une espèce de coordination au
départ informelle mais qui maintenant se
traduit dans des actions très coordonnée
y compris aussi avec les services de
l'état par exemple en région à l'est les
nouveaux entre guillemets
vice-chancelier à l'enseignement
supérieur ont joué un rôle important
aussi dans les dents la diffusion d'un
certain nombre de mesures donc tout ceci
il faudra capitaliser sur ce qui s'est
fait là on a une une coordination une
mobilisation qui est intéressante mais
qu'il faut encore une fois reposés dans
un contexte de cette fois plus plus
pérenne
donc pour pour nous oui à des effets
immédiats qui sont tout simplement
assurer la rentrée et ce n'est pas gagné
parce que je parle pas du côté sanitaire
et des mesures qui seront en vigueur
mais l'enjeu peut-être principal enfin
moi je pense que c'est quand même
peut-être ça finalement qu'il va falloir
réussir en premier c'est recréer le lien
social et recréer la possibilité de
revenir
sur un site universitaire en reprenant
des habitudes d'étudiants en reprenant
des liens avec non seulement les
enseignants mais avec ses pairs ce qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas évident parce
qu'on en tous les témoignages on a des
témoignages
vous avez dit poignet en tout à l'heure
mais c'est le cas de déconnexion avec
ses réalités la réalité alors on sait
que les jeunes il faut aussi garder ça
en tête ont une faculté d'adaptation qui
est réel et à toutes les crises
on a bien vu qu'il avait capacité de
rebondir etc
sauf que là on est quand même dans une
situation un peu inédite et que ça ne se
fera pas tout seul c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir facilitée par des dispositifs
notamment de médiation de remédiation
que va-t-il se passer avec ce qui dans
parcours sup qu'il ne savait absolument
pas ce qu'ils allaient choisir et qui
sont vont arriver là par hasard
ça veut dire qu'il va falloir traiter ça
au niveau de l'accueil des nouveaux
inscrits dans l'enseignement supérieur à
la rentrée 2021 c'est un des éléments
c'est loin d'être le seul donc on a on a
on a le premier enjeu c'est la
socialisation des nouveaux et des
anciens qui reviennent pour l'année
universitaire prochaine et avec des
nouveaux types d'enseignement qui vont
se mettre en place
donc bon tout ceci pour peut-être pour
terminer on a beaucoup parlé et je crois
qu'on rend on a des éléments qui sont
encourageants on a des éléments qui
montrent que le système a bien réagi et
à éviter les catastrophes
maintenant il faut aller au delà de ça
c'est un constat qui évidemment est
essentiel mais il y a quand même
aujourd'hui des cas d'étudiants que l'on
ne sait pas mesurer en volume d'ailleurs
mais qui ont décroché
même si les décrocheurs potentiels que
tout le monde craignait en nombre un
moment des examens
ceci ne s'est pas vérifié les chiffres
des examens sont bons sont pratiquement
identiques aux années précédentes dans
beaucoup d'établissements
donc c'est un signe quand même qu'ils
qui permet de se dire que mon âme des
moyens d'aller rechercher si je puis
dire bon mais il n'empêche que le
décrochage psychologique lui c'est plus
difficile à cerner et c'est à des
éléments qu'on a vraiment du mal à
mesurer aujourd'hui donc il ya déjà des
outils qui se met en place mais l'enjeu
de la rentrée il est fondamental parce
qu'on ne peut pas se permettre même si
moi je veux faire sa petite personne je
ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec la
notion de génération sacrifiée
je pense que c'est pas le bon mot c'est
une génération qui est éprouvée qui est
peut-être pour certains traumatisé mais
certainement pas sacrifier jédir on est
il ya eu des cours il y aura des
diplômes il ya eu des il y aura des
examens
simplement tout ne sera pas résolu par
cela c'est à dire qu'il faudra
retravailler avec les populations
concernées pour que ce ne soit pas
justement une génération un petit peu
entre parenthèses
voilà je m'arrête là et on est
évidemment prêts à répondre à vos
questions
merci beaucoup présentent c'était un
panorama extrêmement complet ce que je
vous propose de faire cher collègue
c'est de vous redonner la parole
monsieur le rapporteur par rapport aux
questions que vous avez posé si vous
avez des compléments et ensuite on va
passer à la lecture des témoignages des
des étudiants et puis j'ai déjà un
certain nombre de
de prise de parole pour vous chers
collègues je vais essayer de distribuer
de façon équitable
si le rapporteur si vous avez quelques
précisions à a demandé juste de
précision a demandé d'abord vous n'avez
abordé qu'à la fin je me l'étais noter
vous voyez on avait abordé la question
du décrochage alors on est dix dans la
présence aux examens cette année on ne
voit pas de deux chiffres en déconnexion
mais entre 2016 et 2020 c'est à dire
indépendamment de de la période qu'ovide
est ce que les chiffres sur le
décrochage s'améliore ou pas est-ce que
tendanciellement on est notamment sur
les première année d'université est ce
qu'on voit une aberration et
deuxièmement vous avez dit que dans les
étudiants les plus en souffrance
actuellement il y avait les étudiants
étrangers
est-ce que vous avez des données sur les
étudiants français à l'étranger qui sont
dans la même situation finalement que
les étudiants étrangers en france
alors sur le décrochage les données de
l'an iv v sont pas les mieux pour
mesurer objectivement ce qui s'est passé
puisqu'on est sur la pente pour une fois
on a plus de donner finalement sur la
perception et sur comment ils ont les
accusions ont ressenti les effets donc
peut-être donné ce chiffre là c'est
celui qu'on a été plus fluide sans doute
que enfin disons qui est différent il
des données objectives serait plus à
demander où est 6e s par exemple qu'il
ya vraiment des données sur les
effectifs de deux réussites ou les de
réorientation mais à l'issue du premier
confinement on avait demandé audience
comment vous voyez les effets sur leurs
études et 57% estimé que la poursuite de
leurs études seraient affectés
négativement par le confinement donc
plus de la moitié avaient le sentiment
que ça aurait des effets à peu près 25 %
des étudiants ont décidé de modifier
leur projet d'orientation en fait au
delà du décrochage ça a quand même eu
des effets à plus long terme sur les
trajectoires 8% souhaité pendant 4 %
souhaitait interrompre leurs études et
9% les prolonger peut-être en percevant
que leur insertion serait plus difficile
donc là au delà des faits objectifs en
tout cas subjectivement il ya eu ses
effets qui ont été perçus et sur la
question des étudiants français à
l'étranger
on n'a pas tellement d'informations dans
l' enquête spécifique sur cette
population
par contre qu'on sait c'est qu'à l'issue
du premier confinement il ya 72 % des
étudiants qui avaient une mobilité
internationale de prévu qui ont dû
l'annuler en fait et pareil sur le stage
on n'a pas donné le chiffre tout à
l'heure 78 % des étudiants qu'ils aient
un stage prévu n'ont pu le réaliser dans
les conditions qui avait été enfin les
conditions initiales il y en a 23 %
qu'ont dû adapter les modalités de leur
stage 17% qui ont vu leur stage reporter
peut-être complètement annulé après 2
juillet et pour 38% il était déjà annulé
en juillet la plupart des témoignages
vont dans le sens que vous nous disiez
et on ressent enfin jeu il ya quelques
expressions un peu un peu forte
je suis épuisée la situation est juste
horrible je suis déprimé je n'y arrive
plus je lâche prise
on nous envoie au casse-pipe ça ça
revient à plusieurs à plusieurs reprises
ce qu'on fait n'a plus de sens n'a plus
de valeur à quoi ça sert et des grosses
angoisses sur la valeur que va apporter
le futur employeur ou la vie
professionnelle à la qualité des
diplômes qui seront délivrés pendant ces
années si particulière et on sent que
ils sont déjà dans l'après crise en se
disant mais mes années 2020 de vilains
l'université qu'est ce qu'elles vont
valoir sur le marché de l'emploi et là
je pense que ça va être une question à
laquelle va être très difficile de
répondre
après sur les examens là il ya quelques
témoignages où les étudiants nous disent
que ils se sont bien passées parce que
c'est un peu arrangé quand même il ya un
témoignage là je le lirai pas mais on
nous dit voilà on nous a demandé de
mentir nous a demandé de mentir sur ce
qu'on rendait de travailler comme si on
était dans une scal c'était pas le cas
donc donc par rapport à ce que vous êtes
ce que vous nous dites sur le niveau des
exams marges sans doute je pense que
c'est vrai mais vous fera peut-être
regarder dans le détail il ya eu
quelques
aménagement de ci de là voilà moi j'ai
deux filles étudiantes
il y en a eu jeune j'ai vu comment la
fait les examens bon c'était utile que
papa de temps en temps soit derrière ça
ça a aidé voilà donc je pense qu'il
faudra il faudra relativiser tout ça
mais encore une fois on va les vallées
publié parce que je pense que c'est un
un retour d'expérience qui est
absolument absolument prodigieux est ce
qu'on sent c'est que ils sont heureux
que on les écoute maintenant et comme
vous le disait très justement on a
l'impression qu'ils ont été des remparts
et est oubliée pendant pendant pendant
très très longtemps que vous nous avez
inventé
je suis vraiment très utilisé d'autant
plus que le premier intervenant à poser
la question concernant les étudiants
également être en berne elle parce que
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup d'ultramar et
qui viennent faire des études en asie
également issus de l'hexagone
et puis à l'étranger y en a également à
l'eau si l'étude portent surtout sur
l'ensemble des étudiants et puis la
prévention la convention pour les
suicides
alors j'aimerais ça va supprimer t en
place des espaces de parole ce que vous
aviez déjà anticipé avant ou depuis est
ce que vous avez eu des éléments qui
concerne la prévention concernant les
suicides et où les tendances suicidaires
les espaces de parole la pelle et un
soutien psychologique
je sais que c'est prévu et je crois même
qu'ils avaient qu il ya eu une
proposition au gouvernement pour
permettre à des étudiants de faire des
visites au moins trois parents
continuent les psychologues et pour le
moment je sais pas si ça se fait déjà
je ne pense pas en tout cas il ya quand
même eu besoin alors est-ce que vous
avez déjà aussi des données pour celà
vous avez cette étude qui était déjà
accroché mais est-ce que vous avez des
données qui concerne évidemment la prise
en charge psychologique de ces plaisirs
du studio et des espaces de paroles
éventuellement qu'ils se mettraient en
place qui pour un merci monsieur
président
merci victoire ensuite sonia de la
provôté puis ses fans pieds-noirs et
enfin scène vas-y souvient beaucoup pour
ces éléments moi j'ai trois questions la
première elle a déjà été un peu évoquée
c'est celle de des différences entre les
secteurs et un secteur particulier se
fait particulièrement entendre et une
promotion particulière c'est celle de
qui vient de deux de se frotter à la
réforme de la première année des études
de santé il est passé les lassos plan
national et est ce que vous avez d'ores
et déjà des éléments plus précis et plus
particulier sur ces générations qui pour
le coup vie manifestement au millième
les difficultés notamment en termes de
détresse psychologique et parce que le
contenu des programmes a été testé cette
année est absolument pas dans les
conditions qui était prévu à l'origine
et donc est-ce que vous avez des d un
avis et des remontées ou en tout cas ce
que vous envisagez qu'il y ait des
études complémentaires sur cette
promotion particulière ma deuxième
question porte sur on aborde beaucoup
les conséquences psychologiques et
psychiques qui sont réelles et toi
bengale d'évoquer ce sujet il ya aussi
un impact physique y est ce qu'on est en
situation de de mesurer cet impact
physique notamment parce que parce que
le fait qu'il ya une moindre activité
physique que iliad et des problématiques
alimentaires notamment d'accès à une
alimentation de qualité correcte
tous ces sujets là qui sont des sujets
j'avais dire assez classique de suivi de
surveillance médicale des étudiants
d'une manière générale parce que quand
on est jeune on ne se met pas toujours
en situation est complètement impeccable
vis-à-vis de sa santé en tout cas les
circonstances font qu'on ne peut pas
mais là clairement où vient de traverser
une période où tout ça s'est aggravé et
à ce qu'on a d'ores et déjà des chiffres
les indices qui permettent de développer
aussi l'état de santé physique de ses
étudiants à l'issue de cette période ce
qui pourrait derrière entraîner des
préconisations et des prises en charge
et un accompagnement supplémentaire
notamment en termes de prévention jeux
wii donc un jour 90 ses fans biennois
qui s'excuse mais il a dû partir ses
mannequins noirs et rapporteur pour avis
des crédits de l'enseignement supérieur
pour la commission culture éducation
plus vous me posez une tissu un peu dans
le prolongement de celle de victoire
n'est ce pas sur le est ce que vous avez
pu mesurer ou sentir le besoin de
consultation psychologue sur les campus
en priorité pour nous on a perçu vous
faisiez bien une différence
sur la mise en difficulté des étudiants
en fonction principalement de leur lieu
d'études et leur établissement
encadrants est-ce que spécifiquement sur
les campus et eu des demandes de
psychologues ensuite hussein et je n'ai
pas oublié la question de céline vous
laisse péronier pour finir je crois
qu'on aura on aura satisfait toutes les
demandes de prise de parole du cn merci
monsieur le président merci mesdames
pour vos témoignages et les informations
observations que vous avez bien voulu
partager avec nous j'aurai besoin de
connaître ce que vous avez pu observer
comment remonter pendant cette première
période de confinement et pendant la
seconde sur l'implication des
représentants des étudiants
si je vous pose cette question c'est que
je suis sénateur de l'hérault donc sur
l'académie de montpellier et je me suis
rendu compte lors du premier confinement
que les représentants des étudiants
étaient complètement absents et nous
avons eu beaucoup de difficultés à
entrer en contact avec les étudiants
pour connaître et identifier leurs
besoins et finalement le seul contact
étaient les assistantes sociales des
crous puisque effectivement on n'avait
pas les pères prs et qui était là et qui
aurait pu nous alerter sur les
situations problématiques
je vous pose ces questions parce que je
siège au conseil d'administration de
deux universités de montpellier en tout
cas je siégeais jusqu'à mon élection au
sénat et au conseil d'administration du
crous et nous avons été fortement
embarrassé pour venir en aide à des
étudiants dont on avait des difficultés
à cerner les besoins et à identifier
justement ce qui leur manquait et fine
le rôle des représentants des étudiants
a été très
en fait absent ils ont été absents dans
les grandes villes comme montpellier et
dans les petites villes ou des moyennes
villes là où la vie associative
estudiantine et moins structurés alors
là ça a été le vide sidéral
en général ce sont les villes de taille
moyenne dans lesquels on ajuste les
premiers cycles et finalement c'était
ses premiers cycles qui était encore
plus précarisés et qui avait encore plus
besoin d' aide et nous avons été démunis
donc il a fallu quelques semaines de
tâtonnements pour identifier des
associations qui n'était pas
nécessairement les associations
étudiantes aux universitaires et qu'ils
veuillent bien aller au contact de ces
publics et qui étaient très éloignées de
nous voilà je voulais savoir est-ce que
vous avez une vision générale du rôle
qu'ont pu jouer les associations
estudiantines j'ai le sentiment que dans
le pendant le 2ème confinement elles
sont un peu plus présenter un peu plus
actifs qu'elles ne l'ont été pendant le
premier confinement pourquoi les
universités donc non pas réouvert de la
même façon que beaucoup d'établissements
d'enseignement supérieur qui se sont
organisés et dans les départements nous
avons été chargés de maintenir les
collèges ou vers les régions ont
maintenu les lycées ouverts
finalement il n'ya que l'état qui a
maintenu les universités fermées
pourtant il ya des organisations toutes
les écoles d'établissements supérieurs
qui ont eu lieu
donc c'est une première question
qu'est-ce qui skie qu'est ce qui empêche
tout ça moi j'ai l'impression que
finalement on parlait de
d'accompagnement des élèves des
étudiants pardon lorsqu il va falloir
redémarrer on sait que la jeunesse elle
et elle est souple elle est innovante
elle est intelligente et moi je fais
confiance aux étudiants pour repartir du
bon pied dès qu'on va les laisser
pouvoir reprendre leur avenir en main
je m'inquiète un peu plus lorsque je lis
les témoignages sur la souplesse des
enseignants est-ce que ils n'ont pas
besoin d'accompagnement pour pour eux
vraiment donné tout ce qu'il faut donner
pour un enseignement qui n'est pas
toujours en présentiel qui peut l'être
mais qui peut être aussi en distance
yale on a vraiment l'impression dans
tous les témoignages et aussi dante sur
nos territoires que les élèves se sont
senti lâché par leurs enseignants ils
ont été accompagnés par leur famille
quand elle n'est pas trop éloigné même
éloignés par leurs animaux de compagnie
mais il le précise à plusieurs reprises
et on l'a on a du mal à comprendre parce
que dans beaucoup beaucoup de deux
branches professionnelles
mais tout le monde a été à la même
enseigne il a fallu s' nous aussi
d'ailleurs se sont organisés pour des
conférences des échanges en visio en
touche qu'on veut et il a bien fallu ça
fait un an que ça dure et on est quand
même étonné de voir qu'il ya des choses
qui restent impossibles dans le milieu
des enseignants on partage tout à fait
le même constat c'est à dire que les
syndicats d'abord rappelons que les
syndicats étudiants
ce sont des syndicats représentés dans
des instances dédiées avec un très
faible taux de participation ouvre
nationale ou au niveau d'ailleurs plus
locale donc il ya déjà un problème de
fond et toutes les discussions autour du
vote électronique des étudiants
s'inscrit dans la démarche qui consiste
à essayer de redonner du sens à la
représentation étudiante institutionnels
j'entends mais il est certain alors je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
améliorée depuis le premier confinement
personnellement parce que tout ce qu'on
peut alors il ya des déclarations
nationale 1 bien entendu mais quand on
voit la réalité des initiatives ce sont
des micros regroupement ou associations
parfois mais y'a même pas d'association
du tout mais d d d d d étudiants motivés
qui se sont appuyés sur d'autres types
de relève et ça a marché ça bien mieux
marché et donc il ya un vrai problème là
qu'il faudra probablement revoir à
échéance c'est peut-être pas la première
urgence mai et non le rôle de relais n'a
pas été ce qui était attendu et n'a pas
correspondu à ce qui était attendu sa
jeu on a beaucoup de remontées qui est
qui qui vont qui vont dans ce sens là
alors sur le décrochage alors là encore
on ne peut pas mesurer quoi que ce soit
nous du décrochage aujourd'hui je
reprends juste que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sur la connexion aux examens moi
je parlais purement vraiment de l'aspect
connexion justement est pas contenu je
je je ne risquerai pas à former des
jugements sur la qualité de ce qui a été
fait pour participer à l'examen ou pas
ou avec une aide ou pas mais en revanche
la crainte était que il est
effectivement beaucoup de déconnexion
est donc de décrochage donc c'était
plutôt cet aspect là qui me que
j'évoquais alors quels sont les
dispositifs alors il y en a beaucoup qui
existe un dans les aidant les dents dans
le supérieur
il ya ce qu'on appelle les services
d'orientation qui sont qui existe il ya
des dispositifs qui ont été mises en
place par les conseils de formation vie
universitaire qui fonctionne bien il ya
toute une série
deux dispositifs qui vont être activés
notamment dans le cadre de la procédure
parcours suppôts fur et à mesure des
étapes donc là on est sur un tir aient
sur un terrain qui est relativement
balisés on a
on a quand même autant pour les
psychologues c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué autant pour un système
d'orientation peut pas parler de
conseillers d'orientation comme on en
parle dans l'éducation nationale mais là
on a vraiment des dispositifs qui qui
monte en puissance un kaki et qui sont
en collaboration avec avec les
responsables de filières notamment être
formation au niveau des instances
universitaires alors dans les grandes
écoles c'est plus cadré et probablement
mais bon on va pas on va pas rentrer
dans l'antre dans les détails sur les
alors ils tendances suicidaires
alors bon on a un chiffre qui a été que
lisa donner tout à l'heure je crois non
non on a mesuré dans le cas de 2016 qui
avait 8 % des étudiants qui avaient
pensé à se suicider au cours des 12
derniers mois
donc ça c'est des archives de 2016 est
en fait c'est beaucoup plus élevé que la
population des jeunes puisque c'est un
peu plus de 3 % des jeunes de 15 30 ans
en population générale
donc ça c'est quelque chose que dit de
manière récurrente un collectif colloque
qui travaillait le centre de la vie
étudiante s'appelle yannick morvan
quand on a une population très
vulnérable en termes de pensées
suicidaires dans la population et une en
revanche les statistiques sur les
suicides
alors vous savez déjà qu'on a un
problème puisque on ne les a pas mais
par contre dans les remontées des cas
que nous connaissons il il n'y a pas de
chiffres marquant sur un nombre de
suicides qui serait beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus élevés etc
mais ça n'est pas statistiques c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas véritablement une
mesure là encore tout à fait fiable
encore que bon les affaires
de lyon etc vont qui se sont passées
elles sont elles sont plus compliquées
quand on les regarde de près ce sont des
gars aussi des situations individuelles
derrière donc c'est difficile c'est une
notion très difficile à manier
parce que parce que les chiffres que
l'on a sont sont difficiles à
interpréter tout simplement donc on a on
a juste nous et ça on en est sûr on a
une tendance effectivement qui est
marquée en termes de pensées suicidaires
pour reprendre la question sur la beauté
est ce que cette tendance elle n'est pas
plus lourde dans le domaine très
particulier des études de médecine
alors vous pensez à la question sur la
la la la réforme de cette année notre
seulement parfois seulement par rapport
à la charge de travail qu'il aurait
demandé par rapport à la responsabilité
aussi qu'on leur impose quand même n'ont
pas de mémoire j'avais lu l'étude
détaillée je pense pas que ce soit
spécialement pour vos études de santé
déjà le chiffre que j'ai donnée celle
enquête 2016 donc en fait ça prend pas
en compte la réforme
et alors là je ne saurais pas vous
répondre moi je préfère ne pas sur la
réforme
clairement il ya une vraie énormes
difficultés sur la mise en place cette
année de la réforme des études de santé
ce bond ce nous on n'a pas du tout
mesuré ça puisque c'est en cours de
l'année s'est elle faisait pas du tout
partie de l'anc est par contre
on a moi j'ai des retours qui montre que
les étudiants sont totalement perdus qui
ne comprennent absolument pas ce qui est
en train de se passer
alors marc compte qu'ils ont très bien
compris c'est les places qui vont être
réservés aux différentes catégories
d'étudiants en course si je puis dire ça
ils ont parfaitement percuté et donc je
pense que c'est une affaire qui va qui
va susciter des discussions au plus haut
niveau donc et kinés qui n'est pas très
fin qui n'est pas complètement
complètement réglé et bon jeu je sais
pas si on sera parce que j'ai pas pu
dire encore qu'on allait travailler en
priorité sur deux sujets pour nous à
lever avec le mobilisation dans un cas
d'une collaboration avec l'inserm donc
on va travailler sur la santé mentale
des étudiants et on va travailler sur la
précarité en essayant de mettre en place
des indicateurs de précarité et là on a
un groupe de travail qui se met en place
avec des économistes avec man d'accord
mais c'est un travail qui n'est pas qui
n'a pas encore abouti
et on aura là des cdd des statistiques
sur sur l'année complète
mais en tout cas bon on sait que
la folie l'année de l'année qui vient de
se passer pour les étudiants en santé a
été probablement encore plus compliqué
pour pour pour ces étudiants là que pour
les autres sur les sur les les mesures
qui existent on a parlé des mois j'ai
parlé des dispositifs d'orientation
on a aussi quand même à noter le succès
si je puis dire des plateformes d'écouté
ça a très bien fonctionné l on était
peut-être un peu longue à se mettre en
place là aussi beaucoup d'initiatives
locales qui s'en s'ont qui se sont
vraiment développer et qui ont qui ont
fonctionné dans des conditions
satisfaisantes alors vous avez vu qu' il
ya eu le chèque
les annonces du ministère assure le
chèque psychologue sur le fait qu' il ya
eu des plateformes de contact des
psychologues
qui est un petit peu répartis sur tout
le territoire et depuis cette semaine on
a une plateforme nationale qui démarre
donc ça va donner de la lisibilité et on
pourra avoir des renseignements plus
précis de ce qui se passe réellement
tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est que il ya
une très très forte demande donc ces
demandes là il va y avoir moyen de la
rendre lisible par cette plateforme
nationale donc ça c'est plutôt bien
et sachant qu' il ya eu vraiment des des
besoins à tous les niveaux la question a
été posée de savoir si on préférait le
contact d'un psychologue ou la
consultation d'un psychologue sur place
ce campus tandis qu'ils n'y sont plus et
pas évident dans la famille c'est encore
moins évident donc les plateformes ont
marché à mon avis à cause ou grâce
pardon à cela c'est à dire qu'il ya il
ya fait une espèce de deux relais qui
permettait d'être écoutés sans avoir
éventuellement aller trop loin dans des
dents dans des confidences qui n'était
que les étudiants n'étaient pas prêts à
fournir dans un certain cercle familial
donc oui il ya déjà des dispositifs
qu'il va falloir regarder et pérenniser
alors vous savez comme moi que les
services de santé universitaire sont
complètement était complètement saturée
dès le 1er confinement alors il faut
dire aussi que il ya des questions de
fond qui se posent depuis longtemps sur
ses services
est ce que une université à vocation
avoir un service de santé avec tous les
spécialistes sur place sur un campus
quand on sait qu'il est éclatée sur le
territoire est-ce que c'est pas plutôt
ce qui d'ailleurs est en train de se
développer de façon relativement
efficace des relais des réseaux de santé
qui travaillent ensemble et qui prennent
en charge
mais avec un suivi à mêmes étudiants qui
part de son service de santé
universitaire mais qui va dans un
certain nombre d'autres secteurs de
façon à ce que la consultation soit raté
enfin intègre toutes les dimensions de
l'étudiant et pas seulement une demande
ponctuelle un moment donné donc là il ya
une vraie réflexion d'ensemble au niveau
national avec avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de la vie étudiante
bien évidemment les plates formes de
chat alors moi j'ai pas du tout
d'éléments là dessus à part ce que tout
le monde peut savoir en relisant les
témoignages sur internet
moi je dirais toutes les bonnes
initiatives tout les sépare dans toutes
les initiatives sont bonnes à prendre
si ça marche si ça si c'est utile pour
les étudiants pourquoi pas après tout
n'est tout ne doit pas être mis sur le
même plan c'est à dire que on les
situations les plus graves il faut
qu'ils aient des vrais processus et les
processus de prise en charge et des
processus de suivi et ça veut dire un
accompagnement personnalisé on y revient
et ça c'est une question de moyens c'est
réellement une question de moyens donc
on va on va avoir cette question qui se
posera bien évidemment à la rentrée de
même que pour les laits tout ce qui
touchera aux questions d'alimentation
alors le crous les crous ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts sur l'alimentation
on est on est on il ya une révolution
presque sur les à la fois en termes de
respect des normes notamment
environnementales diversification avec
des nécessité de respecter les
équilibres selon effectivement le type
de repas préparés et c'est donc il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de progrès
bon je crois quand même que
la période était tellement particulière
qu'il faudra là aussi des bilans je
pense que le cnous procédera à la
restauration procédera vous écouterez
sûrement dominique marchand ici de même
mais je crois que prendre avoir parlé
avec elle elle envisage effectivement de
regarder tous les évolutions récentes
avec cette approche-là c'est à dire
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on peut tirer
deux à la fois de la réponse qui a été
donnée très vite sur les bons les
paniers un euro et c'est bon mais en
même temps d'aller plus loin dans la
réflexion sur quel type de restauration
aujourd'hui parce qu'il faut pas oublier
quand même que les étudiants avaient
déserté les restaurants traditionnels
des coûts ce donc
bon faut trouver la bonne réponse et
encore une fois
[Musique]
alors sur sur la question sur la
fermeture et sur les enseignants qui
n'ont pas été au rendez vous alors je
trouve que c'est un peu sévère parce que
là aussi c'est très inégale
il ya des secteurs où ça s'est très bien
passé
il y en a d'autres où on voit bien à
travers les témoignages d'étudiants ça
n'a pas été le cas
moi je pense que la grande le grand
facteur je l'évoquais tout au début
c'est la formation des enseignants parce
que la formation n'avait pas
suffisamment anticipé la complexité tout
le monde tout le monde devait s'y mettre
certes mais c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose quand on a des cours qui ont
été prévus en présentiel avec
nécessité de les transformer en l'espace
de trois semaines entre cours à distance
et avec une capacité aussi d'accrocher
l'intérêt de l'étudiant il ya des
techniques qu'il ya des ingénieurs qui
doivent travailler dessus en trois
semaines ils n'ont pas pu le faire et je
crois qu'on est on paye un petit peu le
retard qui est qui qui était celui de
certains établissements d'enseignement
supérieur à affronter cette numérisation
que tout le monde savait inéluctable à
plus ou moins long terme donc il ya ce
premier aspect après dans la durée là
encore je pense qu'il faudra qu'on ait
des bilans plus faim parce que on a des
témoignages individuels mais nous on
connaît bien cette difficulté à
l'observatoire de la vie étudiante
il nous faut aller au delà et voir
quelles sont les skis la structure est
véritablement quels sont les points
faibles qui seront à relever ensuite de
façon beaucoup plus précise
il faudra des bilans la cpu là tant que
vous allez aussi écouter et sûrement la
conférence des présidents d'université
envisage d'une série justement de
l'analyse de bilan très précis pour
aller au delà des témoignages prouvent
vraiment il ya une question qui avait
porté sur le rapport au corps et au et à
l'activité physique alors sur laquelle
on n'a pas spécifiquement interroger les
étudiants pendant confinement notamment
sur l'activité physique par contre on
les a interrogés sur leur alimentation
et leur consommation d'alcool parce que
ça nous paraissait être un sujet
important dans ses pas complètement la
question qui a été posée
mais ce que ce qu'on a recueilli dans l'
enquête confinement c'est que un quart
des étudiants ont jugé que leur
alimentation avait été moins
satisfaisantes pendant le confinement et
surtout les étudiants qui n'étaient pas
rentrées chez leurs parents en fait il y
en a qui ont été plus satisfait
finalement leur alimentation pendant
confinement quand ils sont retournés au
domicile familial et 14 % ont déclaré
avoir consommer plus d'alcool que
habituellement et
ceux qui étaient seules 10 % ont déclaré
avoir consommé de l'alcool tous les
jours contre cinq pour cent dans
l'ensemble et 1% en temps normal donc il
ya quand même eu une hausse de la
consommation d'alcool pendant le
confinement et puis on avait aussi des
questions mais là c'est plus en lien
avec la précarité puisque un quart des
étudiants dont les difficultés
financières se sont aggravées pendant le
confinement ont déclaré ne pas toujours
manger à leur faim pour des raisons
financières
donc voilà c'est aussi ça nous permet
aussi de voir que ça a eu sans doute des
effets sur leur santé physique sur leur
alimentation voilà ça c'était le
peut-être le premier point je voudrais
juste revenir aussi sur la question des
enseignants si chaud parce que je me
sens un peu concerné et je voulais pas
partir des chiffres de l' enquête je
voudrais rappeler que d'entendre est
dans le pré lors du premier confinement
avec toutes les difficultés que ç'a eu
de passé les cours en ligne
il ya quand même 77 % des étudiants qui
nous ont dit qu'ils avaient eu des
échanges avec leurs enseignants que 73%
avait eu des supports de cours mis à
disposition et que 69 % déclarent avoir
eu des cours ou des réunions de travail
en visioconférence alors je viens
peut-être pas d'université qui est
représentatif donc je peux pas
m'exprimer pour l'ensemble des collègues
mais du côté des enseignants il ya eu
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de travail et ça
occasionnait un surplus travail très
important ça veut dire scanner les
copies de tous les étudiants pour leur
faire un retour les recevoir en visio
faire des cours sur logiciel à distance
avec des partage d'écran très compliqué
donc je sais pas si on peut dire qu'il a
pas eu d'investissement c'est sûr c'est
nous c'est en tout cas je pense que
j'estime ans il faudrait une formation
et les situation était très différente
selon les universités sont les moyens
dont les universités disposer mais en
tout cas les étudiants alors il était
malgré tout pas complètement satisfait
ça on voit aussi dans les verbatim que
39 % et seulement était satisfait quand
on voit le pourcentage normal c'est
beaucoup moins mais les insatisfaits ils
sont plus nombreux parmi ceux qui
avaient une mauvaise connexion internet
qui avait pas d'ordinateur personnel à
disposition qu'avait pas des bonnes
conditions de travail
donc je vois là sans doute qu'il ya des
choses qu'on pas été mise en place assez
vite à l'université mais vu
l'investissement que sa demande et
l'épuisement dans lequel sont les
collègues
ça me paraît difficile de dire que les
ans et ce qui n'est pas complètement
impliqué mais encore une fois je parle
d'un point de vue situé cette question
est alors je voulais juste aussi parce
qu'on n'a pas répondu à la question sur
les violences sexistes et sexuelles qui
était une des questions qui avaient
déposé initialement
donc c'est effectivement des nouvelles
questions qui ont été introduites dans
l' enquête cette année sur la suivante
c'est la suggestion d'une langue d'une
équipe de l'ined qui avait travaillé sur
l' enquête virage donc à dv déjà de
l'expérience sur ces questions et ça
nous a permis alors c'est l'intérêt de
le faire passer dans une enquête
généralistes comme celle de l'ové je
sais que ça évite des billets qui sont
liées au tas la thématique de l'enquêté
qui pourrait biaiser un peu le taux de
réponses est donc ce qu on a distingué
dans l' enquête ce qui concerne les
propos les attitudes ou les propositions
à caractère sexuel d'un côté et puissent
les étudiants qui avaient été victimes
d'attouchements sexuels ou de rapports
sexuels forcés
donc il ya les propos et les attitudes
et puis les actes alors quand on met
ensemble propos attitude ou propositions
on mesure dans l'anc être que 4% des
étudiants ont été victimes de violences
avec d'un côté 3% propos attitude ou
propositions et puis attouchements ou
rapport sexuel forcé c'est un pour cent
des étudiants donc c'est des prévalences
qui peuvent paraître en août un
pourcentage plus élevé mais quand on
ramène au nombre d'étudiants qui sont
quand même 3 millions en fait ça fait
beaucoup de cas à l'université et on
voit des effets d'abord sur la suite des
études puisque c'est des étudiants qui
vont avoir plus de mal à se concentrer
et qui vont pour certains abandonné
leurs études
et puis souvent beaucoup d'étudiants qui
ne vont pas en parler forcément et qui
vont garder ça pour eux et avec les
problèmes que ça peut poser ou qui vont
en parler uniquement à leur entourage et
pas dans les services universitaires ou
pas à des acteurs universitaires alors
ce qui concerne maintenant la question
des discriminations
c'est une question qui existe depuis l'
enquête précédente en fait l'enquète
2016 dans laquelle on a introduit d'une
part l'origine migratoires des étudiants
et d'autres pas le sentiment d'avoir été
traité différemment c'est comme ça que
la question est posée après leur demande
aux étudiants d'après eux quelle est la
variable qui a joué dans ce traitement
différent donc on n'utilise pas le terme
aux discriminations
ça s'est calé sur les enquête de l'ined
ça évite de créer des billets pareil
dans l'est dans les réponses et donc ce
qu'on mesure c'est que 10
pour cent des étudiants considèrent
avoir été moins bien traités que leurs
camarades pour la notation l'orientation
le rapport avec les enseignants ou avec
les camarades et que pour 23% de ses
étudiants cette différence elle est liée
à leur origine ou à leur nationalité
pour 12% à leur couleur de peau pour 11%
à leur sexe l'identité de genre pour 10%
à leur apparence et 7% leur religion et
ça c'est des filles qui sont stables
entre 2016 et 2020 est-ce qu'on a
introduit comme question dans l' enquête
c'est des questions sur les agressions
verbales les insultes ou les injures
pour ceux qui avaient déclaré des
discriminations en raison de leur
nationalité origines couleur de peau ou
religion et parmi ces étudiants on voit
que six sur dix ont déclaré avoir fait
l'objet de moqueries plaisanterie
répéter mise à l'écart ou roger et que
un sur trois a déclaré avoir subi des
agressions verbales insultes 20 jours
pour répondre aux questions
moi je voulais une dernière question et
je crois que vous avez très largement
répondu déjà mais c'était sur le
programme d'études complémentaires que
vous allez engager suite à cette enquête
générale
j'ai noté la mise en place d'indicateurs
de de précarité
et puis aussi un travail sur la santé
mentale exploitation plus en détail mais
beaucoup plus important avec un coût de
l'exploitation qui travaillera sur
l'ensemble des sujets d'accords juste
pour pour finir sauf si des collègues
ont des ondées complément moi je voulais
vous vous interrogez sur parce que nous
sommes au sénat et la relation un
territoire
nous nous intéresser à plusieurs
reprises vous avez dit que cette crise a
interrogé la relation des universités
des établissements quels qu'ils soient
avec avec les territoires et vous nous
avez dit que la notion de grands campus
universitaire et j'ai bien noté qu'il y
avait une différence avec les campus des
grandes écoles qui ont eu une autre une
autre façon de réagir que cette notion
de grands campus universitaire
aujourd'hui a été questionné parce qu'on
se demandait si elle pouvait encore
répondre à un certain nombre
d'interrogations
est ce qu'on peut faire une opposition
entre le grand campus universitaire moi
je suis d eau saine donc je pense bien
évidemment à nanterre mais dans le
département il y à un autre système jean
monnet a plutôt des annexes il y en a
une autre à notre asso est ce qu'on peut
imposer ses cds ces deux modèles et moi
je vais vous faire part juste de mon
expérience d'élu dans la commune où je
suis je voulais entrer en contact avec
la population d'étudiants ce n'est pas
possible
la mairie ne sais pas comment toucher
les étudiants qui habitent chez eux les
campus on les connaît les résidences on
les connaît mais les étudiants qui sont
sur la commune et auquel on aimerait
apporter une aide aujourd'hui sont plus
connus par les domaines il faudrait
passer par les universités ce qui est
absolument impossible donc même quand on
a l'ambition l'envié de les aider
matériellement on peut pas parce qu'une
population étudiante pour pour un maire
c'est quelque chose qui est complètement
insaisissable voilà c'était de question
que je voulais vous vous posez la
présidence
sur les deux aspects c'est à dire quand
j'ai évoqué les grands campus je pensais
plus à la réorganisation en cours et à
la fusion d'université ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose en termes de
conséquences sur la répartition
territoriale des parce que je suis je
prends bordeaux par exemple il reste un
campus central mais il ya toujours des
jeux pas si on peut appeler ça des
antennes ou des sites délocalisés
donc il ya deux dimensions moi j'ai
évoqué les établissements fusionnés qui
sont aujourd'hui un petit peu à la
pointe des établissements notamment de
recherche dans les classements
internationaux enfin bon il ya voilà ils
sont pas très nombreux mais ils ont
acquis une taille internationale qui
leur permet de encore une fois
d'impulser de porter des politiques
notamment sur le numérique je pense
il se trouve que j'écoutais tout à
l'heure en venant ici
françois germinet donc le présidente de
cergy et qu'ils étaient interviewés qui
qui évoquait justement ses dimensions de
différenciation entre les établissements
et il va falloir prendre en compte les
deux types d'évolution
donc je pensais plutôt à ça mais ce que
ce que vous évoquez c'est à dire le fait
qu' on souffre depuis très longtemps
d'une absence de vraie définition de ce
qu'est un campus universtaire français
on n'a pas
on n'a pas l'histoire on n'a pas la
culture ni anglo saxon d'un côté ni
europe du nord de l'autre ou même ce
qu'on peut trouver en suisse qu'on peut
trouver dans certains pays européens qui
sont sont pas tout à fait sur notre
modèle dont on a on a peut-être à se
poser effectivement des questions qui
sont liées à l'urbanisation qui sont
liées à la nécessité d' équité de
traitement des étudiants sur l'ensemble
des territoires sur la façon dont dans
une métropole comme paris ou l'île de
france
on arrive à créer une véritable vie
étudiant et je pense que les outils qui
vont se développer notamment les hits
des outils numériques
il ya beaucoup d'exemples à l'étranger
qui montre on peut parfaitement organisé
une vie étudiante avec des outils
numériques on pas que mais ça aide
parce que ce que vous évoquez aussi à
savoir une mairie ne connaît pas ses
étudiants sur son territoire ça c'est
sight c'est vrai depuis très longtemps
et ça évolue très peu parce que soit
l'étudiant effectivement et sur un
campus entre guillemets c'est à dire sur
une antenne ou sur un site soit il est
dans une structure locale il habite tel
territoire il travaille peut-être là où
il donc il n'y a pas de lieu
symboliquement qui permettrait de dire
voilà sur tel mais sur telle ville sur
têt la rendre sur tel département etc
il ya que le niveau de la région qui
commence à pouvoir donner ce type de de
dénuement donc on n'a pas enfin je veux
dire c'est la crise ou pas crise la ce a
mis en relief la nécessité de contacter
des étudiants et de les aider donc
concrètement comment les cons les joints
donc ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya des
problèmes de communication avec les
étudiants aucun étudiant de consulter sa
boîte mail institutionnels tout le tout
passer par les réseaux sociaux et ça
c'est une réflexion que iliad il ya des
exemples à l'étranger qui marche très
très bien d'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux d'utiliser les mêmes outils que
les étudiants pour les joindre et
les pour les faire travailler ensemble
et pour les faire se rencontrer entre
guillemets virtuellement donc là c'est
un champ on n'en est qu'au début on n'a
pas encore les outils en france vraiment
approprié il faut faire très attention
de ne pas tomber dans du gadget et dans
des plateformes qui servent à rien et
qui s'essouffleront d'elle même
donc les universités sans son pouvoir
discuter avec avec le nouveau bureau de
la cpu en sont très conscientes un de
ces de ces enjeux là il faut il faut
utiliser à la fois tout ce qu'on va
apprendre de cette crise mais aussi tous
les toutes les innovations potentiel que
ça dégage
il faut utiliser ça pour progresser
justement sur cette dimension de vie
étudiante moi moi ce qui me satisfait je
dois dire beaucoup
c'est que c'est bien la première fois
depuis très longtemps que la vie
étudiante est au coeur des discussions
et des préoccupations des établissements
qui jusqu'à présent sans son passé il
faut quand même dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont je ne dis pas qu'il se
passait rien mais ça n'était pas un
élément de stratégie
bon ben on sait et c'est en train de
changer parce que tout simplement ça
change parce qu'il ya la crise mais ça
change aussi parce que la qualité de la
vie étudiante et je pense que vous avez
dû voir tout y'a pas mal d'articles qui
sortent notamment de sociologues sur la
nécessité d'aller vers la prise en
compte dans l'évaluation des
établissements et des formations delà du
bien-être et de la qualité de vie
étudiante bon ça c'est un élément qui va
être un facteur d'attractivité
internationale quand les échanges vont
redémarrer
combien de fois nous on a perçu les
difficultés dans les universités de dire
ben oui mais nous vous savez on n'a pas
grand chose en terme d'accueil
le seul vrai campus à paris qui existent
et la cité internationale universitaire
et qui n'est pas sur le même créneau
donc on
voilà tout tout tout ça va quand même
être à mon avis réinterroger de façon
assez profonde et notamment notamment
par les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur
[Musique]